[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: If you've
used AdMob Mediation,
you've seen this
little slider that
says Optimize when you set
up your Mediation config.
Typically, there's some
additional input elements
asking for things like
API keys or OAuth tokens,
and you may have thought,
what's the big whoop?
Why do I need to bother
chasing down all those keys?
Well, it's actually
a very big whoop.
By hitting that slider
and entering the values,
you give AdMob the
ability to figure out
what that mediated network is
paying you-- real live dollars
and cents.
With that information,
AdMob can order the networks
you hit for you based on
what you're actually earning,
which helps you maximize your
revenue for each impression.
So the next time you're
setting up a Mediation group,
make sure you've got network
optimization turned on.
You'll be making AdMob smarter
and better able to help
you get the revenue you need.
[MUSIC PLAYING]